my grandfather went into World War one
on a horse on a horse now if you've ever
ridden a horse but if people are
shooting at you it's just not the best
place to be you're high off the ground
they shoot the horse and you're now in
mobile and you may end up underneath the
horse and it's all very bad in that
regard 20 years later when both of my
parents got involved in war war World
War two nobody who was fighting a war
did it on a horse
everything changed in transportation in
just 20 years so let's do it again let's
make all-electric cars let's make all
the electricity from wind and solar just
that world leaders all showed up in
Paris this year is a fantastic thing
furthermore the United States president
showed up there the president whether
you like him or not is the most
influential single guy in the world
single person in the world and he went
to the trouble to go there committing
the United States to reducing greenhouse
gas emissions over the next few years
and they all agreed to get together
every five years and check on each other
see if the other countries are holding
to their commitments now the trouble is
if a country is making more carbon
dioxide than they agreed to in 2015 then
it agreed to in 2015 there's not too
much anybody can do about it except
world opinion is very important world
leaders are very interested in what
people think of them and us or their
country and as I say all the time if the
US were leading the u.s. were out in
front on energy technology everybody in
the world would be following the same
way everybody in the world knows who
Mickey Mouse is if we had a culture of
renewable energy people would have would
embrace that culture and use renewable
energy the biggest news in science this
year for me was the US which is the
world leader in all this energy burning
of
also fuel burning and and using a lot of
energy per person the u.s. now has 53
percent of our population who believe
that humans are causing climate change
so 53 percent is enough to get elected
president
and so maybe climate change will be an
issue in the next presidential election
here in the United States and that will
influence the whole world a few weeks
ago I was in West Virginia and I got a
an email from somebody in the speaker's
organization the organization that led
to my being hired to speak there the
Clay Center in Charleston West Virginia
here in the United States and it said
don't talk about coal it's a very
sensitive subject here the president's
policies have greatly affected the coal
industry and so on his own when you're
in that part of the world they have a
technology called mountaintop removal so
they take off the tops of these very
high hills these mountains and there's
the coal all at this level all over the
state of West Virginia and it ruins the
local ecosystems the streams get full of
all this crud there's use these slurries
to pump powdered Cola round use
explosives and they destroy the forests
that was there so when I did this talk
despite this warning from somebody I got
a standing ovation when it came out on
stage I did a talk which was not me it
wasn't bad I got a standing ovation
after that then there was a
question-and-answer session like this
and I got a standing ovation after that
now it ain't about me all I'm saying is
people in West Virginia are also kind of
tired of the coal industry there's
30,000 coal jobs in West Virginia that's
a lot or is it if you go to a typical
professional baseball game they're about
twice that many people if you go to
professional football game they're way
more than twice that many people so it's
a lot of jobs but it's not that many
jobs
if the state of West Virgina north of
West Virginia were to change from
coal-burning to wind energy and solar
voltaics photo Volta soaking up sunlight
to make electricity or even some
concentrated solar where you concentrate
sunlight to make heat they would have
50,000 jobs over at least the next 20
years we cannot continue to burn coal
everybody I mean this is not
controversial
except here and there but what I'm
saying is I was warned against talking
about coal but I talked about coal and
people responded very favorably to not
burning any more coal so I think there's
a little bit of a disconnect there in
the politics many of the citizens would
rather not be decapitating their
mountains and destroying their streams
instead would like to exploit the wind
that blows through there's another by
the way another charming thing because
the mountains are the way they are in
that area it concentrates the wind in a
few places so it's actually what have it
West Virginia would have a slight
advantage over nearby counties for
certain wind applications so you guys
speed open-minded anyway we work
together we can change the world the
Paris conference was a big start a big
step people will be talking about the
Paris conference for decades because I
really believe is a turning point